WE'RE GOING TO THANK THE
DEMOCRAT PARTY FOR 2020.
PANEL, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THAT TONIGHT.
AND THE SAME NETWORK THAT PATTED
ITSELF ON THE BACK FOR THE
JOURNALISM THEY CONDUCTED
THROUGHOUT THE INVESTIGATION DID
MORE OF THAT SAME JOURNALISM
LAST NIGHT.
HERE'S CNN'S ANDERSON COOPER.
BADGERING WHITE HOUSE PRINCIPLE
DEPUTY PRESS SECRETARY, HOGAN
GIDLEY.
>> WHAT DEMOCRATS HAVE WANTED
FOR SO LONG IS FOR --
>> DEMOCRATS WANT?
>> FOR THE PRESIDENT TO BE
GUILTY.
>> IF HE HAD ANYTHING ON HIM, HE
WOULD BE INDICTED TODAY.
HE WASN'T BECAUSE THEY DON'T
HAVE THE EVIDENCE.
>> DID THE PRESIDENT LIE?
>> THEY HAVE TO PUT UP OR SHUT
UP, ANDERSON.
>> DID THE PRESIDENT LIE?
>> NO, I'M NOT AWARE OF HIM
LYING.
HE HADN'T LIED TO ME.
>> DO YOU FEEL BAD YOU'RE SCARED
TO SAY YOUR BOSS LIES.
I WOULD NOT WORK IN THAT
SITUATION.
>> I JUST SAID NOTHING --
>> WITH ME IS HOGAN DIDLEY,
HOGAN, I WILL -- LOVE WATCHING
IT ON TV.
LET'S TALK ABOUT YOUR BOSS.
ANDERSON?
LET'S TALK ABOUT MR. ZUCKER.
LET'S HAVE A CONVERSATION.
BECAUSE THIS IS -- THIS LITTLE
GOTCHA GAME, WE CAN GO TWO WAYS
WITH IT.
EVERYBODY FEELS -- BECAUSE
THEY'RE HOSTS OHHEN A CABLE
NETWORK THAT CABLE CAN BE TURNED
ON ALL OF US.
I'M ALWAYS IN THE CROSS HAIRS.
BUT WHAT WAS THAT LIKE BEING ON
SET.
IT WAS ONE HIT AFTER THE OTHER.
OBVIOUSLY FOCUSING ON THE TEN
OBSTRUCTIVE ACTS.
>> SURE, LISTEN, FIRST OF ALL,
NOT GOING TO TAKE A LECTURE ON
TRUTH TELLING FROM ANYBODY IN
THE MAIN STREAM MEDIA WHO'S BEEN
LYING ABOUT THIS PRESIDENT FOR
THE LAST TWO YEARS, TELLING THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE THAT DONALD
TRUMP COMMITTED TREASON WHICH IS
A CRIME PUNISHABLE BY DEATH AS
YOU WELL KNOW.
WHAT YOU DIDN'T PLAY IN THAT
CLIP AFTER HE SAID THAT I TOLD
HIM YOU HAVE A PANEL FULL OF
LIARS EVERY SINGLE NIGHT ON THIS
SHOW.
>> DARN --
>> OH.
>> THE POINT IS, FOR ME TO SIT
THERE WITH CNN AND LISTEN TO
THEM, WHO THEY WANTED THIS TO BE
TRUE SO BADLY.
SO MANY IN THE MEDIA DID, AND I
UNDERSTAND WHY THEY DON'T DROP
IT.
BECAUSE IF THEY DID, THEY WOULD
BE ADMITTING THE FACT THAT THE
LAST TWO YEARS OF THEIR LIFE WAS
A COMPLETE AND TOTAL WASTE.
>> MITT ROMNEY TONIGHT RELEASED
A STATEMENT.
I'M SICKENED AT THE EXTENT AND
PERVASIVENESS OF DISHONESTY AND
MISDIRECTION OF INDIVIDUALS OF
THE HIGHEST OFFICE OF THE LAND
INCLUDING THE PRESIDENT.
HE WENT ON TO SAY READING THE
REPORT IS A SOBERING REVELATION
OF HOW FAR WE'VE STRAYED FROM
THE ASPIRATIONS AND THE
PRINCIPLES OF THE FOUNDERS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF OLD MITT
ROMNEY COMING OUT?
>> WHAT'S SOBERING IS THE FACT
THAT MITT ROMNEY WOULD JOIN IN
WITH THE CHORUS OF PEOPLE WHO
REFUSE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE FACT
THAT AFTER, YOU KNOW, $35
MILLION AND 1.4 MILLION
DOCUMENTS AND COUNTLESS HOURS OF
THE PRESIDENT BEING AN OPEN BOOK
ALLOWING ALL OF THIS TO BE PUT
FORTH, PUBLIC, NOT ASKING FOR
REDACTION, NOT MEDDLING AT ALL,
NOT FIRING ANYBODY, ALLOWING
THIS TO GO FORWARD, HE WOULD
JOIN WITH THE DEMOCRATS AND SAY
WE WANT MORE.
I'M TELLING YOU THIS RIGHT NOW
THIS, IS NOT MOVING THE GOLD
POST, THIS IS CHANGING STAID
WILLIAMS.
WITH EAR IN A WHOLE OTHER BALL
GAME.
YOU CAN LET THE DEMOCRATS WORK
IN THE WHITE HOUSE, GIVE THEM
TOP SECRET SECURITY CLEARANCES,
LET THEM STAY IN THE OVAL ALL
DAY AND SLEEP IN THE RESIDENCE
AND IT WOULDN'T BE ENOUGH FOR
THEM.
THEY WANT SOMETHING ELSE.
>> I DON'T REMEMBER ANDERSON
COOPER WITH SUSAN RICE ACROSS
THE TABLE.
GO TO THE SUNDAY SHOWS AND SAY
THE BENGHAZI ATTACK WAS STARTED
BY SOME ANTI-ISLAMIC VIDEO.
WHY DID YOU DO THAT?
MAYBE HE DID IT, I'M FORGETTING
IT.
I DON'T REMEMBER THE SAME
FEROCITY OF THE CRITICISM.
LOOK, YOU WORKED WITH THE
PRESIDENT FOR SOMETIME NOW.
I KNOW HIM QUITE WELL.
HE'S TOUGH.
RIGHT?
HE CAN BE TOUGH.
BUT HE'S ALSO FUNNY AND
CHARMING.
BUT HE'S DEMANDING.
AND I NEVER -- I'M NEVER RATTLED
BY A DEMANDING BOSS.
IT'S SOMEONE WHO WANTS TO HOLD
THE BAR HIGH.
AND I KNOW HE WANTS TO SUCCEED.
HE WAS FRUSTRATEDLE WIT
HE WAS FRUSTRATED W WIT
HE WAS FRUSTRATED WEWIT
HE WAS FRUSTRATED WE AT
HE WAS FRUSTRATED WE ALL KNOW
THAT.
HE SAID PUBLICLY, I'M GOING
AFTER HIM.
I'M BLANK.
HE WAS REALLY ANGRY.
HE TOLD A LOT OF PEOPLE A LOTF
OH THINGS.
HE WAS REALLY ANGRY.
WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU ABOUT
HIM?
AND DID HE EVER TELL YOU OR
ANYONE YOU KNOW TO GO OUT AND
TELL AN UNTRUTH?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT?
I'VE NEVER HAD A CONVERSATION
WITH HIM LIKE THAT AT ALL.
AND LET'S BE HONEST, ANY RED
BLOODED AMERICAN WHO'S FALSELY
ACCUSED OF A CRIME FOR TWO PLUS
YEARS WOULD PROBABLY BE A LITTLE
UPSET ABOUT IT, ESPECIALLY WHEN
YOU KNEW THE FACT THAT YOU HAD
DONE NOTHING WRONG.
NO COLLUSION, NO OBSTRUCTION, A
COMPLETE AND TOTAL EXONERATION.
AND THEY PUSHED THIS LIE.
AND THEY HAD THE NUMBERS I WAS
LOOKING AT SINCE MAY OF 2017,
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" HAS PUT OUT
1,156 STORIES ABOUT MUELLER,
CNN, 1,965.
AND MSNBC TOPS MORE THAN 4,000.
THEY JUST CAN'T GET PAST THE
FACT THEY DIDN'T GET WHAT THEY
WANTED HERE.
THEY WANTED A CONVICTION.
THEY WANTED A SMOKING GUN.
THEY HAD NO EVIDENCE.
AND LIKE I SAID LAST NIGHT, IF
BOB MUELLER, SPECIAL COUNSEL,
HAD ANYTHING ON THE PRESIDENT,
HE WOULD HAVE INDICTED.
PROSECUTORS PROSECUTE, BUT THEY
ONLY PROSECUTE IF THEY HAVE THE
EVIDENCE.
HE DIDN'T, AND THIS IS A
COMPLETE AND TOTAL EXONERATION
OF THIS PRESIDENT.
>> THIS WAS SHIFT TODAY ON
MSNBC.
LET'S WATCH.
>> AN IMPEACHMENT PROCEEDING
CANNOT BE SUCCESSFUL IF ONE
PARTY DECIDES THEY'RE MORE LOYAL
TO THEIR PARTY OR TO THE PERSON
OF THE PRESIDENT THAN THEY ARE
TO THE CONSTITUTION AND THE
COUNTRY.
>> THE GOP HAS NO INDEPENDENCE
FROM THIS PRESIDENT.
IT HAS MADE ITSELF EFFECTIVELY A
CULT OF TRUMP'S PERSONALITY.
>> THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES IS TOO WEAK TO CONFRONT
VLADIMIR PUTIN WHEN IT COMES TO
ELECTION INTERFERENCE.
AS LONG AS THEY INTERFERE ON HIS
SIDE, HE MAY BE GRATEFUL.
>> I DON'T RECALL HIM BEING
UPSET THAT IT ALL HAPPENED UNDER
OBAMA'S WATCH.
BUT YOU CAN REACT TO ANY OF
THAT.
APPARENTLY THE PRESIDENT IS JUST
TOO -- IS HE STILICH
TOO -- IS HE STILLCH
TOO -- IS HE STILL COLLUDING
WITH RUSSIA?
>> I HEARD HIM ON THE SAME
NETWORK ON THE CLIP YOU PLAYED
EARLIER WITH SOMEONE ELSE ON
CNN.
HE DIDN'T FEEL AS THOUGH IT WAS
TIME TO MOVE FORWARD ON
IMPEACHMENT BECAUSE HE DIDN'T
HAVE OVERWHELMING AND
DEMONSTRABLE EVIDENCE.
WAIT A MINUTE.
YOU'VE BEEN TELLING AMERICA THAT
YOU HAD THE EVIDENCE.
YOU'VE SEEN THE COLLUSION.
YOU KNOW IT EXISTS.
NO ONE PUSHES UP AND FOLLOWS UP
AND SAYS, HEY, WHERE'S YOUR
EVIDENCE RCHLT YOU GOING TO STEP
DOWN FOR LYING TO SOMEONE FOR
TWO YEARS?
ARE YOU GOING TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE AT ALL?
IT'S DISGRACEFUL.
>> STETLER IS TWEETING OUT, 29
DAYS SINCE A FORMAL PRESS
BRIEFING, NOT A SIGN OF THE
CONFIDENT WHITE HOUSE.
WHEN'S THE NEXT BRIEFING?
>> I DON'T KNOW, THE PRESIDENT
MAKES THE CALLS ALL THE TIME, HE
TELLS US WHEN HE WANTS US TO GO
OUT.
WE GAGGLE MULTIPLE TIMES A DAY.
THEY DON'T WANT TO GAGGLE.
>> THEY HAVE TO GET THEIR OWN
CAREERS AND GET CONTRACTS WITH